the afternoon panel is devoted to the
topic of energy sources disruptive
energy technologies and policies and
it's a pleasure to introduce the
moderator for the afternoon panel the
Honorable Stephane Dion Stefan is a
member of the canadian parliament since
1996 from 2006 2 2008 he was a leader of
the Liberal Party of Canada he was a
minister of intergovernmental affairs
between 1996 and 2003 and minister of
the environment from 2004 2005 so he
can't hold on to a job apparently as
Minister of the Environment he secured
one of the greenest budgets in the
history of canada and in 2005
contributed to the rescue of the Kyoto
Protocol while chairing the UN
conference on climate change in Montreal
safan has also been a member of the YC I
external advisory board since we started
in 2009 so please welcome Stephane Dion
thank you very much mark is an honor to
work with you in the for for honoring
dr. Pachauri and for this conference on
energy future and climate change leads
it in gentlemen the title of our panel
is disruptive energy technologies and
policies I will ask two questions to our
four panelists the first one is what is
the most likely scenarios facing off
energy future and climate future and the
second one is if these scenarios are bad
as they are likely to be what kind of
policies would you suggest to implement
as soon as possible to give us a better
future for our energy and climate future
what I will do in order to set the stage
is to yes I will do it it's to sum up
the the likely scenario if we do nothing
more than what we are doing that means
the business-as-usual scenario the
current policy scenario according the
IPCC the integra metal panel of climate
change and dr. Pachauri will say more
about that later this afternoon and
according the international energy
agency so very rapidly very rapidly what
it gives to us as you know the
scientists are telling us that we should
do our best to limit global warming to 2
degrees Celsius beyond the
pre-industrial level of warming but
according to the IPCC the baselines the
baseline scenarios without additional
giving us gas mitigation result in
global mean surface temperature
increases in two thousand and 100 from
3.7 said degree Celsius to 4.8 so we're
in trouble we should be at
too and we may go to well-being four
degrees countries are aware of it so at
cancun they committed to do more and
each country came with the pledge but
according to according the ipcc if all
the countries are consistent with their
pledge reach their commitment we are
still facing a warming of three degree
Celsius instead of two and some of these
countries if not many of them will miss
their target for 2020 unfortunately it
will be the case for Canada my country
so the IPCC is saying what we need to do
in order to keep fifty percent of
chances to stay around two degrees
Celsius of warming is to decrease our
emissions the world emissions between
forty and seventy percent for 2050 and
to continue down until the end of the
century 42 seventy percent the
international energy agency is saying
that in order to to have a chance to do
that we need to start right now they say
that for 2035 will need to decrease or
energy-related carbon dioxide emissions
by 31.4 percent when in fact it will
increase if we do nothing more than what
we are doing baidu thirty six percent so
short story if we continue the pet we
are our emissions will go up by a third
between now in 2035 when it should go
down by the third and remember that
remember that the world economy will
more than double between now in two
thousand and thousand and thirty five so
we need to decrease our emissions by a
third with a economy that will be twice
the size of the economy we have today
that that means that we need to be much
more energy-efficient that what we are
according the International Energy
Agency global energy demand demand will
grow by
forty-five percent between now and 2030
five it should grow by only fourteen
percent in order to stay in the path of
two degree Celsius of warming fourteen
percent for an economy doubled with
which will twice the size of the one it
has today we'll need also to decrease
our use of fossil fuels oil gas and coal
that are accounting for eighty-two
percent of global primary energy demand
now and our first seemed to stay at
around eighty percent for 2035 with the
current policy so Dario when we need to
decrease it by at least 2 66 a tutor for
2025 in order to keep a chance to avoid
global warming well over two degree
Celsius very concretely that means that
for the use of barrels of oil per day
which is 87 million now if we continue
the path in which we are it will go for
2025 x 111 millions of barrels per day
when instead we should decrease it to 78
million barrels per day which means 33
million zobelle per day lower than the
current policy scenario the same for
coal coal will increase by forty four
percent with the current policies in are
you for 2035 when we should find a way
to decrease it to 30 by thirty three
percent by a third instead of allowing
it to grow by forty four percent this
with the scenario where capture and
storage would be common practice but
it's not what we are doing in fact
Humanity is subsidizing fossil fuels
five times more than renewable energy
according the international energy
agency now in fact we should not
subsidize fossil fuels we should put a
price on carbon according to the
international energy energy agency for
2035 we should have a price that
of co2 of 125 daughters for developed
countries and around one hundred dollars
for emerging economies because everybody
must do something more than what
countries are doing now we keep need to
keep in mind that that non-oecd
emissions account for forty five percent
of world edition now in 2050 seven
percent now and more than two-thirds in
2035 chinese emissions are exceeding us
emissions by sixty percent now it will
more than double us emissions in 2035
with the common with the current policy
scenario all these are not Chris a
crystal ball it's only projections but
it's the trouble in which we are it's
not a rosy scenario but fortunately we
have four great experts that will tell
us how we may avoid it what kind of
ideas they have what kind of ideas they
have to help us to have a more rosy
scenario with sound policies and weight
way to boost the right technologies so
we'll hear first alms uml ohms was at at
Stanford University where it did this PG
on this very topic which is energy
scenarios for Climate stabilization and
from Stanford he went to Berkeley but in
the meantime it did a lot of things
especially recently he was the senior
policy advisor in the US Department of
Energy office of policy and
international affairs after will hear
from Nebojsa neki say no ve it told me
that I'm allowed to call you na ki and
Jackie is a deputy director-general and
deputy CEO of the International
Institute for applied system analysis
and professor of energy economics at the
vienna university of technology if i
have
title that long maybe I would have
succeeded to become Prime Minister of
Canada and your research interests
include long term patterns of
technological change economic
development and response to climate
change and in particular the evolution
of energy mobility and information and
communication technologies after will
hear from Richard Lester Richard is the
Japan steel industry professor and head
of the Department of nuclear science and
engineering at MIT and its latest book
is unlocking energy innovation how
America can build low-cost low-carbon
energy systems and finally Vanessa
Stewart is the chief operating officer
and co-founder of salt page a
full-service renewable energy company
that develops finances and operates
solar energy stations on client
structures across the USA so each of
them will have between five and ten
minutes no more to introduce their
thoughts about how we can get out of
this mess and after I will allow each of
them to ask question to each others it
will have a very lively discussion
between them and we'll keep at least 20
minutes for questions the questions will
be the same system that this morning you
will have a card that you were you right
to question you sending it to me and it
will ask the questions to any of the
panelist so let's start with i said i
will start with ohms you know the floors
is yours
while the visual aids are coming up I
want to thank everyone at Yale for
welcoming me back I was here just about
six weeks ago for a second appearance in
a seminar series that's hosted by the
Institute it's been lovely to be here
but I want you to know how much of an
honor it is to be a part of your program
today in fact is made more special by
the fact that naki is here on this panel
and professor tongue earlier I have
studied under each of them more than a
decade ago and though I didn't follow
them into academia I have done my best
to take the insights of their expertise
and apply them as the senior policy
advisor at the Department of Energy over
the last four and a half years and what
I'd like to do in the next few minutes
with some visual aids is to give you an
insight of how the tools of their trade
can be applied to some of the high
stakes decisions that are framed by the
problems that the department of energy
analysts do face thank you very much for
inspiring me to follow that pursuit I
want to take issue with the opening
premise of our gathering today by
talking about some of the species of
analytic products in our field first of
all I was asked in the invitation to
speak about things that would be likely
to happen in the future or forecasts for
2030 and like Professor st earlier this
morning I had a resistance to the
question when posed there we go the
fundamental element of a forecast is
that you have some notion of the
probability that the outcome will occur
we do have forecasts in this business
this is an example of a forecast that I
looked at every 90 days very carefully
we looked at this forecast but I want
you to see that the bounds on the
forecast are statistically constructed
by confidence intervals that are defined
and divided derived from market activity
so it's actually groupthink manufactured
group think we are looking at what
everybody else thinks will happen in
order
to interpolate things that we think
might happen and as far as we can see in
this kind of scenario two years at the
most this is the kind of intelligence
that we get under the product name
forecast of course we're responsible for
making decisions that have impacts
implications far further in the future
than two years but we're really not able
to assign probabilities successfully
with high enough confidence intervals to
use this kind of product so we go to a
different kind of product and outlook
and an Outlook answers a different kind
of question what if the prevailing
conditions persist these are the kinds
of results that you get when you ask
that type of analytic question a kind of
look like a straight ruler right into
the future up up and away and every year
people complain about this work product
they say this is definitely wrong this
definitely cannot be our future why are
they such bad forecasters you know it's
not a forecast it is an Outlook that
tells you what will happen if prevailing
conditions persist and if you are an
appointed official in the Department of
Energy it is your job to make sure that
prevailing conditions do not persist the
question you are actually being asked on
a daily basis is how will the choices
that you make change this trajectory and
in fact we do an awful lot of policy
analysis to ask ourselves how big of an
impact would we have if we adopted this
policy or another policy if we don't
have this product we actually don't have
anything to fly by when we're thinking
about the impacts of our actions that's
why out looks are important they are
always wrong but they are a good gauge
of your level of ambition and your
potential for contribution now outlooks
themselves fade away after a few decades
really we it's preposterous even after a
couple decades three is stretching it
already so I want to introduce you to my
view of the scenario which is the craft
that Yassa has made famous world round
for decision analysts in the energy
field scenario gives us a chance to ask
creative questions about what will
happen if the prevailing
conditions do change and it doesn't
necessarily mean that we have taken the
actions that change those conditions it
could allow us the chance to explore
inevitable surprises in the field and
ask ourselves what risks we may face if
we are not hedging our bets against one
type of technology investment sanara the
theme or another this is a product from
the international energy agency that
shows you a current policy scenario at
the top this is excuse me this is a
world energy demand and it shows you
that if they were to assume that we
could adopt some additional policies we
might do a little bit better in terms of
demand but if we were serious about that
two degree target that we just heard
about that we would certainly need to
take additional actions these are the
kinds of insights that one can derive
from well-constructed scenarios but even
this scenario is very short term in my
view 20 30 doesn't give us enough
visibility about the implications of our
actions allow us to take in the full
period of time for the diffusion of new
technologies that might actually be
responsive to the cause of our time so I
want to look squarely at climate it's a
theme for the climate and energy
institute here it's not the only
decision criteria that I needed to use
as the senior policy advisor the
Department of Energy was constantly
calling on me to use decision criteria
related to national security or
prosperity or jobs but let's just take
Climate stabilization for a moment here
I want to return to your consciousness
the landmark contributions of those
people who built the representative
concentration pathways that have formed
the basis of analysts for working group
three and others in the most recent IPCC
report here you can see that there's
four centuries of future beyond the date
which most scenario analysts stop
calculating their results 2100 but there
is a multi-sensory scale of implication
about the choices that we do make in
this century related to the way we
change the chemistry
of the atmosphere so I'm going to
presume for discussions sake that we are
aiming for the representative
concentration pathway that will get us
the best chances of achieving a two
degree stabilization scenario here is an
exercise conducted by the international
energy agency that presumes that that is
the policy objective that you have
determined you want to pursue and then
back casted from it what you must
achieve in order to stay on track here
in the bottom line of these three is the
course that they charted that was the
closest to the representative
concentration pathway that would give us
the best chance of stabilizing below 2
degrees and look at 2100 they can
calculate no further but they have
already come to a place where they have
a profound insight from their analysis
in the year 2075 the energy sectors
carbon footprint is eliminated in fact
the International Energy Agency let it
be known to all of the OECD decision
makers the Department of Energy receives
these briefings personally that in order
to have a good chance of staying on this
path we need to did contemplate an
energy sector that was carbon free by
the end of the careers of most Yale
students today that means that every
major infrastructure project that every
current ell student could invest
themselves in for the rest of their
careers needs to contemplate that if it
includes carbon it is a stranded asset
and potentially a liability the same is
true for major nation states around the
world now to close I wanted to give you
a piece of my own research which is a
look at any scenario that would come out
of any model that might try this kind of
analysis where we ask ourselves the
question what resource portfolio excuse
me this is from IEA still what resource
portfolios are consistent with the
objective of eliminating carbon dioxide
by 2075 I wanted to finish this part
from IEA because they answered the
question for us they charted here to the
best of their ability out to 2075 the
composition of the energy resource
portfolio that could achieve that target
and then they concluded this appears
possible but it will be very challenging
and our analysis gives us results that
are highly uncertain meaning this cannot
be construed as a likely outcome or a
forecast the trends in this scenario get
us to a place where we are close but a
gap remains that may need to be closed
through additional technologies meaning
we don't currently know a combination of
technologies that will get us there for
me that means that we need to look
towards where we might find the types of
technology sets the systems of
technologies that can move the needle
and here's where I want to introduce you
to the work that I've contributed in our
space how we can interpret the policy
implications of scenarios from all of
these different modeling teams I like to
use the decomposition that was
introduced first by Professor kaya from
Japan but extend extend it more broadly
where those of you who are
mathematicians will see quite simply
that I have created expanded identity
that allows us to look at the driving
factors here we are able to see that we
could achieve a very aggressive
stabilization scenario with no palpable
change in human welfare the population
and GDP factor need not move
dramatically for us to achieve our
objectives but we do need to make
progress on energy efficiency or the
amount of energy that our economy
requires and we knew need to continue to
improve efficiency in the supply chain
of our energy system from primary energy
to in use but look at what happens in
this scenario that was produced by the
United States's own national
laboratories premier modeling team here
you see the carbon intensity of the
energy supply becomes dramatically
different as they try to achieve a
stabilization scenario as aggressive as
2 degrees what they're telling us here
is that their model
finds at least cost path that shows
aggressive substitution on the supply
side of the meter not necessarily on the
demand side and then in this last graph
you see the fraction of carbon dioxide
in the energy system that is emitted to
the atmosphere this my friends this is
dramatic so the leading national lab in
the United States that's participating
in the intermodal model comparison team
is telling us that the least cost path
they can calculate gives us a
breathtaking display of aggressive
replacement of thermal power plants in
the United States with carbon capture
and sequestration at the same time the
IEA is telling these nation states that
our research and development portfolios
aren't keeping pace with that kind of
technological optimism and that if
you're really planning to bank the
planet on the kinds of graphs that I
just showed you you need to put your
money where your mouth is at a national
level the Department of Energy has tried
to do that with the Recovery Act and the
rpe breakthrough technologies are our
best contributions I will close by
showing you four graphs from a report
that I'm proud to have called revolution
now from the Department of Energy that
shows you my friend Levi Tillman was
responsible for this graph how we can
actually see that investments in
technology convert into the kinds of
deployment that would be relevant to the
cause of our time thank you very much
for giving me a chance to give you a
tour through those analysis
you